make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin you know just when you think
that that you get where tom taylor's
going and you understand what he's doing
here here he comes
pulling the rug out from under everybody
[Laughter]
tom taylor man like this here come that
boy
[Laughter]
it's kind of nuts right tom taylor is
such a ridiculously gifted writer uh
it's
it's it's crazy how talented he is right
so uh we're picking back up with
deceased dead planet in the last video
that we had we had john constantine
zatanna uh detective chimp we had these
guys uh you know blue devil you know
basically kind of like the the vertigo
more or less side of dc comics the magic
mystery that kind of thing uh who were
who were basically helping to launch a
dimensional uh mission alongside swamp
thing to find out why a portion of the
green
was basically calling out and struggling
right and the reason why is because
remember
swamp thing's wildly powerful right he
can he's he's part and parcel to the
green which means having him on your
side
is basically having control of the world
and swamp things this force where it
almost seems like he's the one thing
that couldn't be overcome
by the anti-life equation right but he
could just kind of merge with the green
and that would be it now it really does
beg the question
if swamp thing became infected would
that mean the entire earth would become
infected right that's a legitimate
question to ask i don't really know i
mean i guess maybe it would turn into
like the happening right where like the
plants were killing people that terrible
m night shyamalan movie but
what this does is it kind of opens up
with the aftermath of the fact that
plastic man had attacked all of them
right they had discovered this what
looked like a giant moat
along with this fortress that was
surrounded by hellfire only for us to
discover that it was plastic man right
that the plastic man
had been infected kind of gone awry and
was literally trying to consume
everything right trying to kill them and
all that kind of stuff now this also
pointed the finger to how strong plastic
man is right how like dangerous he is
as a character but what it does is it
picks up with with zatanna basically
being woken up by constantine detective
chimp and because of the fact that
they're surrounded by hellfire
it's the one weapon they have at their
disposal because in dc comics hellfire
works a little bit differently than
marvel comics
in marvel comics you do have hellfire
which can be used by like uh by like the
ghost riders people like that but it's
not this all-encompassing thing right
it's not like
everything that's exposed to hellfire
will be destroyed and eradicated and
that's it right that like you know if
galactus were hit with hellfire he would
die and if thanos were engulfed in
hellfire he would die doesn't really
work that way in dc
it more or less seems like it does now
when it comes to the spectre i'm not 100
sure about that but the overall gist is
that hellfire can
and will destroy everything that comes
into contact with it and so that's when
zatanna basically pops out and uses
their magic to basically force plastic
man
into hellfire and that completely and
totally destroys him right that
eradicates him quickly
um if i'm being honest with you guys it
is a bit disappointing i would kind of
like to have seen a little more of
plastic man but i guess you know one
scene where plastic man's infected is
the same as 100 scenes where he's
infected right it would all just kind of
go the same way but it would have been
kind of cool because he is really like a
one-man army and he would be more than
enough himself to take over the world
right to basically infect everybody or
to kill all the superheroes who were
left he's just that capable but of
course after basically mourning their
dead right they lost ragman they lost
blue devil after mourning their dead
they kind of say okay like now it's time
for us to go and and basically figure
things out right like to figure out
what's going on with the screen
and so where you end up having like all
these undead monsters that kind of come
running up on and right all these
infected who come running up on him
bullet fire comes out of nowhere and
it's coming from this base
and that's we end up finding out that
within this base are basically the
richest
villains in marvel comics right oswald
cobblepot maxwell lord uh you know jason
blood like all these guys who were super
rich
are all here the villains have found a
way to survive which is kind of wild
because the way they've done it is
actually pretty screwed up what we end
up doing here is actually jumping back
to damien wayne and uh and his role is
batman now
damian wayne is basically working on the
cape of superman that was damaged right
he's sewing the cape and where jim
gordon basically encounters him he's
like you know batman was never really
much of a sewer the response to damian
is that's one of the biggest faults of
batman
is that he you know batman should be
totally self-sufficient right batman
should sew
and it's really kind of damien meeting
jim grayson and actually hugging him
right now the reason why this is so
significant is twofold one because
anybody who's been reading dc comics for
any measure of time knows that damian
wayne
is not the emotional type right he's
emotional insofar as he's a teenager so
his hormones are going nuts right like
every teenager was like that uh and so
he's emotional in that way
in the sense that like his body is just
kind of going crazy because of all the
chemicals and everything that are being
pumped through hormones and whatnot
but it's also a big moment because of
the fact that damien taking on the role
of batman
we didn't really know what it was going
to look like we had some
some ideas we had some perspectives from
you know stories from days gone by
but we didn't really know exactly what
it was gonna look like here and damian
wayne
is a far more emotionally intelligent
batman
than bruce wayne was right that bruce
wayne was just emotionally
stunted he was shut off he was never the
guy to give you a hug he was never
really the guy to tell you he loved you
right it was the things he did in lieu
of that that let you know that bruce
wayne cared about you right but he was
never really the guy to let his guard
down that's one of the reasons why tom
taylor's one was important because you
saw that
in a lot of different ways but with
damian wayne you know he's just kind of
like you know i'm a human being just
like everybody else and it's cool it's
amazing to kind of you know to see that
the other cool thing that we get here is
that dr fate shows up and tells damian
hey uh superman's waking up right so
like you know john of the kids waking up
uh he'll want to see you and so
basically it's kind of like okay let's
make our way towards superman you know
to jonathan now this is something that
i'm not fully on board with
right something that i'm not fully huge
on jonathan kent
being uninfected i'm not fully on board
with that and the reason why is
we know that like bites right fluid
transfers saliva different things like
that
seem to be a big mode of transmission
like we know that because that's how
like black atom was infected right in
exchange of blood we know that like the
the primary way of being infected when
it all popped off was
looking at a computer screen and
basically being infected with the
anti-life virus that way but once people
were infected the anti-life virus
started becoming biological meaning it
was transferred through fluid exchange
and so
it stood to reason that if a sword was
used
to stab through superboy to you know to
stab through jonathan and to kill wonder
woman that when that sword was pulled
out wonder woman's blood would come with
it and it would pull through jonathan
and he would basically
you know experience some flex of her
blood in his own system
and that would lead to him being
infected it looks like tom taylor's just
kind of like yeah don't worry about that
just kind of on with the story i guess i
kind of get where he's coming from uh
and and maybe that's just a little too
nuanced right maybe i'm just splitting
hairs a little too much but it's
something that i kind of expected
after seeing that like i kind of
expected that to go down but in place of
that we get something that's actually a
lot cooler and something that kind of
makes a lot more sense
right so uh when jonathan wakes up he's
met with mary marvel and mary marvel's
just kind of like hey so like you know
you
basically passed out you know you were
injured uh you know dr fate's healing
abilities were able to kind of restore
you back to health
and uh and of course you know i was the
one who was able to kind of patch you
back up get you bandaged that kind of a
thing
what it looks like because jonathan
doesn't recognize her immediately he's
like you seem familiar but i don't
really know who you are once she
transforms
we almost get this little bit of a of an
indication that like there's a possible
romance blooming between these two
characters and that makes
perfect sense and it's something that i
didn't really realize that i wanted to
see
until i saw it and i was like i kind of
want to see jonathan ken superboy and
like mary marvel as a couple it
seems cool we're like i would ship these
characters like i would say does anybody
say that anymore do people still say
that like you [ __ ] people
like like they're a couple like you see
them as a couple and like you know
like i don't know that's still a thing
but if it is i i like i that right i
i i do that i see that i ship them right
i don't know
i'm trying to keep up with you young
people right and your phrases
your words that you guys use i don't
know i'm old i'm out of touch
[Laughter]
but i kind of see this going down and
it's it's cool it's really really cool
but from there we switch over to
constantine right we switch back to john
constantine alongside zatanna and with
you know swamp thing and so on and swamp
thing of course recognizes yes
this is the place where the green is
calling out where the green is is is you
know being tortured more or less the
other thing that we find out here is
that with all these rich villains here
that what they've done is they've
basically found a way to maintain the
class system right the the higher-ups of
society and the poor individuals of
society and the way they maintain this
is really kind of like a nonsense
explanation by them in the sense that
it's kind of like you know okay
so like the way this works you've got
the richest individuals here
and then you have those individuals you
know those those people who were saved
that basically their families are the
ones who were like cleaning and cooking
and all that kind of stuff and the
service they offer is their exchange for
shelter so basically it's if you want to
survive in this shelter you got to clean
and the the reason why we don't have to
do any of that is we're giving you this
shelter right
so we're giving you a thing and you're
basically you know staying within the
shelter by providing us with a service
and it's kind of like okay but like this
is the apocalypse though so like the
notion of like hey you can stay here so
long as you have something to offer
that kind of goes away and it's
basically like hey so like you know any
one of us out there could die right like
anyone else out there could perish and
it's kind of a funny thing because the
question that has to be asked here is
what stops these people from rising up
what stops these citizens there from you
know from
all these people who are working from
just like killing all the villains well
then of course you get guys like jason
blood and jason blood showing up is of
course he's the other half of etrigan
it's basically kind of like the bruce
banner incredible hulk dichotomy albeit
etrigan was long before bruce banner in
the incredible hulk but jason blood as a
lot of you guys probably know
gone the form of man arise the demon
etrigan that's basically what happens
uh and when this when this takes place
basically you get like one of the
coolest revelations
that when etrogen pops up he wants to
talk to john constantine separately and
when constantine asks why
the response of etrigan is because
hell's pissed hell's mad right now like
technically all these people out there
these anti-living
they should all be dead but they're not
their souls are still locked inside
their bodies and hell's mad because
they're not getting their hands on their
souls and when the question of
constantine is why should we care about
that
the response of etrigan is because
trigon's coming because trigon is going
to come to earth
and he's going to cleanse this whole
place and he's going to get their souls
like he's going to kill everybody here
and as soon as i saw this i was like oh
my god dude like world building man like
and here i don't know what it is man tom
taylor loves trigon he
loves dragon and i don't really know why
but while the two of them are talking
it's literally etching and saying like
nothing here is going to be able to stop
him and that's true
because from the previous works that
we've seen just through the power of
trigon and even like in the injustice
line of comics the only thing that was
able to stop the power of trigon
is is like somebody like mixol pitilic
right like him and dragon being locked
in like eternal battle in the void right
kind of like just this endless space
that stretches on forever and that they
can never escape from right it was the
only way to like save the world right
save all of reality from being torn to
pieces but it's one of these things
where
where you know tom taylor always kind of
presents us with this scenario where
trigon is just like this immutable
indestructible force that exists out
there right like the top tier of hell
lords basically that you know i don't
really know how he relates to lucifer
morningstar my knowledge on on dc comics
isn't that
strong it'd certainly be worth
investigating but it'd certainly be
worth me looking into just
to get a better understanding but in the
middle of their conversation suddenly
shots start popping off everybody starts
shooting and the reason why once they
get inside is because
swamp thing is going crazy and what
swamp thing discovered is that what the
villains did
is they took the fluoronic man right
they took jason woodruff now jason
woodruff those of you guys who don't
know he originally appeared back in the
atom number one in 1962 and then became
the fluoronic man in the flash
in issue number 245 in 1976 uh jason
woodru was basically an
enemy of the atom for some time but then
eventually managed to get his hands on a
serum that allowed him to merge with
plant life and following that he was
kind of this swamp thing-esque character
he had a pretty big role i think during
alan moore's swamp thing run
but uh but basically he can tap into the
green and he can communicate and control
the green and the reason why that
matters is because what the villains
have been doing
is using him as a means to like force
him to grow
like food and things like that for them
right so they literally are more or less
torturing the guy they made a slave out
of him and that's why the green is
calling out that's why the green is
tortured because it's the it's
it's not so much the green as it is the
fluoronic man communicating through the
green
he was basically sending out an sos
right he was sending out a call for help
to anybody in the green that could hear
him and swamp thing picked up on it
right and that's why they're here
it's literally humanity torturing you
know this this power that they have and
so you get this amazing moment
where you have swamp thing who's of
course being shot at being attacked and
it's one thing to kill the henchmen
it's another to kill the guys who are
running the show and when maxwell lord
when he gets his hands on maxwell lord
he literally tells him you will free the
fluoronic man and that's why lord's like
no we don't take orders from you and
then he
not like he rips the head he literally
pops the head off of maxwell lord he
killed one of the one of the big guys in
charge right in response to that
you end up having uh oswald cobblepot
who says like professor ivo
it's time now anybody who knows anything
about dc comics
knows who professor ivo is professor ivo
is the guy who made
amazon the amazon android the guy who
has all the powers of the justice league
and amazo comes flying in
and basically like like you know attack
swamp thing which forces him
to kind of back off now of course
suzanna jumps in super fast and forces
amazo to freeze but then that's when
constantine says hey he's not the only
one that there are other amazons here
like they've made a bunch of amazo
androids and so basically like they have
to leave right they've got to get out of
there as fast as they can because if
they don't they're all gonna be killed
now swamping of course wants to stay and
he wants to protect
uh or wants to get jason woodru out of
there assuming he's really even still
alive but at the very least like
eliminate how the villains are able to
use the green for their own ends but at
the end of the day it's like we just
gotta go like we just gotta run and so
once they get out of there what you also
end up finding out
is they've got a veritable army of
amazo's and what it looks like if i'm a
betting man here because villains are
pretty are very predictable
what it looks like is they're going to
use amazo's and they're going to
basically take over right they're going
to wipe out all the infected that are
out there they're going to conquer the
world for themselves
and create their own new world order
right that's what villains and the ultra
rich would probably do like they would
probably
try to create their own new world order
and so this leads to
of course us picking back up with gotham
city right with with uh
the giant green you know building more
or less and constantine picking back up
with like you know cyborg and superman
and all of them and his cyborg talking
to them about the cure remember cyborg
knows that there is a cure
the problem is he doesn't know how to
access it right he doesn't know how to
get into it because he can't access that
kind of information despite the fact
that he's a walking talking mother box
he can't really access that kind of info
and what they need is new god technology
that cyborg can basically use to access
that information the problem is that
apocalypse is basically gone right
there's only one place
left to get new new god technology and
that's new genesis
the land of high father the issue with
this is one does not simply walk into
new genesis and demand information from
high father
they've got to basically sneak in and
there's only one person out there that
can sneak them into new genesis
only one person that can do it and john
constantine knows who it is right the
damian wayne hits on this idea
that if there's an anti-life equation
there must also be the life equation i'm
not even going to tell you guys what
that means
anybody who's been reading anybody who's
read jeff john's green lantern run
knows what that statement means the life
equation
yes so we'll probably end up seeing
those guys hanging around sometime
uh who knows when fingers crossed
hopefully we do but
this leads into uh into constantine
basically telling
you know cassie sandsmark who's the new
wonder woman i need your lasso of truth
and then tell me superman i may need you
at some point although i don't need you
right now
i've got to go make a stop somewhere uh
give me a little while right so we
basically pick up kind of out here in
the middle of nowhere this this wood in
the shed and we end up finding out that
constantine
is meeting with mr miracle he's meeting
with scot-free now scot-free has for the
most part given up remember
vic barto was one of the first people to
fall and scot-free watched it happen
that he couldn't save her and the two of
them were married very much in love and
it makes him feel like a failure
right that he couldn't save his girl as
any man probably would i can't think
i can't really think of a man who
wouldn't be able to save his girl and
wouldn't feel bad about it right i mean
that's really not much of a man at all
but uh what this does is it leads to him
just kind of being like okay
i'm not falling for whatever ruse you
have like remember constantine isn't
necessarily like a god of tricksters but
he is usually a guy that always has an
ulterior motive
and he'll he'll manipulate and do
whatever he needs to do in order to
achieve that ulterior motive but that's
when he tells mr miracle i'm not lying
i'm not duping you i'm not tricking you
we need to go to new genesis if you
don't believe anything that i'm saying
then ask me and he presents him with the
lasso of truth what a smart move right
small things like that are what make tom
taylor's story so great and that's when
basically he presents
the last lasso goes around constantine's
hands and he says scott there's a cure
we can save big barta we can bring her
back and that's enough for scot-free
that's
all he needs right to to know that
constantine's telling the truth and
there's a way to save big barta from
there it's dude get cleaned up
get a shower get washed we're gonna go
back to the superheroes we're gonna
pitch this plan
and then we're gonna go to new genesis
because what we need is help
stealing the throne from a god but with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you